다시 돌아오신 걸 환영해요, Quantum Computing in Practice. 오늘은 에피소드 6이에요. 제가 정말 좋아하는
양자 컴퓨터 응용 분야 중 하나인 자연 시뮬레이션에 대해 집중적으로 다뤄볼 거예요. 이번 에피소드에서는
어떤 종류의 양자 역학 문제에도 적용할 수 있는 단계들을 설명할 거예요. 양자 역학 문제란 어떤
양자 시스템의 상태가 시간에 따라 어떻게 변하는지 찾는 문제예요. 먼저 큰 그림으로 살펴보고, 구체적인 예시를 통해
자세히 살펴볼 거예요. 바로 양자 유용성을 입증한 2023년 IBM 실험이에요. 간단한 동기 부여로
시작하자면, 양자 컴퓨팅 분야에 있는 우리가 계속해서 반복하는 가장 유명한 이야기 중 하나가 있어요.
바로 Richard Feynman이 1959년 Caltech에서 강의를 하면서 기본적으로
수십 년 동안 이 분야 전체에 동기를 제공한 이야기예요. 그 강연의 제목은 "바닥에는 충분한 공간이 있다"였는데
재미있는 제목이지만, 기본 아이디어는 미시적 수준에서 아직 발견되지 않은 풍부한 물리학이 많다고 주장한 거예요.
그때 그 이야기는 큰 주목을 받지 못했어요.
그러다 80년대에 기술이 상당히 발전하면서 주목받기 시작했어요. Feynman은
시간이 지나면서 자신의 메시지를 더 명확히 다듬었어요. 그는 80년대에 Caltech으로 돌아와서
"컴퓨터로 자연 시뮬레이션하기"라는 또 다른 논문을 발표했는데, 여기서 그는 컴퓨터가 자연과 정확히 똑같이 할 수 있는
정확한 시뮬레이션의 가능성에 대해 이야기하고 싶다고 구체적으로 밝혔어요.
본질적으로 원자 수준에서 일어나는 일에 대한 조잡한 근사를 없애고, 이를
양자 물리학을 이해하고 활용하는 컴퓨터로 대체하는 거예요. 자연이 하는 것을 단순히 시뮬레이션하는 것이 아니라 에뮬레이션하는 거죠.
이전 에피소드에서 보여줬던 타임라인 그래픽을 기억하시나요? 한쪽 끝에는 쉽게 해결할 수 있어서
양자 컴퓨터의 속도 향상이 필요 없는 문제들이 있어요. 반면 다른 쪽 끝에는 아직 우리가 갖지 못한
내결함성 양자 기계가 필요한 매우 어려운 문제들이 있어요.
다행히, 우리는 현재 작업할 수 있는 중간 영역에 꽤 많은 시뮬레이션 문제들이 있다고 생각해요. 그래서
이 전망에 흥분되고 흥미를 느낄 이유가 많은데요, 자연 시뮬레이션이
많은 흥미로운 응용 분야의 기초가 되기 때문이에요. 몇 가지만 예를 들자면, 자연을 더 잘
시뮬레이션할 수 있다면 새로운 소재 발견을 가속화하고, 더 나은 의약품과 의학을 만들거나
입자 물리학이나 우주론의 새로운 물리학을 탐구할 수도 있어요. 하지만 여러분이나 저 또는 누구든 이런
흥미로운 분야에 양자 컴퓨팅을 적용하려면, 우선
전형적인 시뮬레이션 기반 워크플로우의 기본 단계들을 이해해야 해요.
먼저 관심 있는 양자 시스템을 파악해야 해요. 이를 통해 시간
진화를 지배하는 해밀토니안과 초기 속성이나 상태에 대한 의미 있는 설명을 알 수 있어요.
그런 다음 이 상태의 시간 진화를 구현할 적절한 방법을 찾아야 해요. 이 재료들이
정리되면, 다음 단계는 실제 실험을 수행하는 거예요.
일반적으로 시간 진화 알고리즘의 quantum circuit 구현을 최적화하고,
circuit이나 circuit들을 양자 하드웨어에서 실행하고 결과를 후처리하는 과정이 포함돼요. 그래서
시뮬레이션 실험에 관련된 기본 단계를 다음과 같이 정리할 수 있어요.
시스템 해밀토니안 파악, 해밀토니안 인코딩, 상태 준비, 상태 진화,
circuit 최적화, circuit 실행, 그리고 후처리예요.
이 단계들은 꽤 자세한 내용이에요. Qiskit 패턴 프레임워크의 네 단계를 기억하시나요? 이 프레임워크는
Qiskit에서 루틴을 구현하는 방법을 이해하는 데 도움을 주는데, 매핑, circuit 최적화, circuit 실행, 그리고
후처리로 구성돼요. 그래서 여기서 처음 네 단계는 실제로 모두 매핑이라는 큰 범주에 포함되는데, 그래서
우리가 이 첫 번째 단계 전체를 한 에피소드로 다룬 거예요. 못 보신 분들은 이전 에피소드로 돌아가서 봐주세요.
이제 코딩에 들어가기 전에 이 단계들이 실제로 무엇을 의미하는지 먼저 살펴봐요. 시뮬레이션 실험을 수행하기 위해
가장 먼저 해야 할 기본적인 일은 시스템을 설명하는 해밀토니안을 파악하는 거예요. 때로는
이미 잘 알려진 것들도 있고, 전체 시스템의 작은 부분들의 에너지 기여를
이해해서 조합해야 할 때도 있어요. 여기서 hi는 h의 n개 부분 시스템 중 하나에 작용하는 해밀토니안이에요.
또한 기본 입자를 다루는 경우에는 시스템이 페르미온으로 구성되는지 보존으로 구성되는지 확인해야 해요. 다음으로
해밀토니안을 인코딩해서 양자 컴퓨터가 이해할 수 있는 형태로 변환해야 해요. 보통
이런 해밀토니안들은 기본 입자나 스핀 시스템으로 구성돼요. 페르미온이나 보존을 시뮬레이션하는 경우,
Jordan-Wigner 변환이나 Bravyi-Kitaev 같은 인코딩 변환을 선택해야 해요. 이런 변환들은
원래 구성 요소인 페르미온이나
보존의 형태로 작성된 해밀토니안 정의를, 양자 컴퓨터의 gate로 쉽게 변환되는 파울리 연산자로 변환하는 방법을 알려줘요. 예를 들어 Jordan-Wigner
변환은 여기서 정의된 것처럼 페르미온 연산자에서 파울리 연산자로의 매핑을 제공해요. 이미
스핀 1/2 시스템을 다루고 있다면, 이는 매우 일반적인 경우인데, 가능한 정규화 계수를 제외하고는
인코딩 체계를 사용할 필요가 없어요. 원하는 해밀토니안을 양자 컴퓨터의
gate 세트로 인코딩한 다음, 시뮬레이션을 시작할 적절한 초기 양자 상태를 결정하는 것이 중요한 다음 단계예요.
이 상태는 이상적으로는 연구 중인
시스템의 물리적 의미나 구성을 반영해야 해요. 예를 들어, 분자의 바닥 상태 에너지를 탐구하는 데 관심이 있다면
Hartree-Fock 근사나 실제 바닥 상태와 상당히 겹치는 쉽게 준비할 수 있는 다른 상태로
시작할 수 있어요. 초기 바닥 상태의 선택은 VQE 같은 변분 알고리즘의 수렴뿐만 아니라
변분 양자 솔버의 정확도와 효율성에도 영향을 미쳐요.
양자 위상 추정의 시간 진화나 샘플링에서도 마찬가지예요. 본질적으로 초기 상태는
계산의 출발점으로, 양자 시스템에 대한 유용한 관측량을 추출하기 위한
무대를 설정해요. 여기서 ci는 계산 기저 상태이고 ai는 임의의 n qubit 상태 준비예요.
각 상태의 계수와 2의 n 마이너스 1 정규화 조건은 일반적으로
연산자 o로 상태를 초기화하는 방식으로 접근할 수 있는데, 시작 상태는 모든 값이 0인 표준 기저 상태이며 단순화를 위해
이렇게 표기하는 경우가 많아요. 일반적으로 이는 지수적인 수의 C-NOT gate가 필요해요. 대부분의 경우 우리는
시스템의 특정 초기 상태에 관심이 있고, 그 준비는 합리적인 양의
리소스로 구현할 수 있어요. 예를 들어 qubit들이 서로 얽혀 있지 않은 곱 상태는 단일
qubit 연산만 필요해요. 이제 사실 트로터화에 대해 아직 이야기할 기회가 없었는데
여러분 중 일부는 이미 익숙하실 거예요. 본질적으로 트로터화는 행렬 지수화를 계산하는 방법으로, 비가환
연산자의 지수적 특성을 처리하기 위해 근사를 사용해요. HA와
HB와 같은 두 연산자가 교환되지 않으면, 영리한 트릭을 사용해서 각각의 지수인
e의 iHA와 e의 iHB를 n번
교대로 적용해야 해요. 여기서는 증명을 다루지 않을 거지만, 설명란에
이 내용의 간단한 증명 링크를 공유할게요. 핵심 메시지는 이거예요. 시간 진화는
매핑의 중요한 부분이에요. 트로터화는 연속적인 상호작용을 양자 컴퓨터에서
구현할 수 있는 이산적인 단계들로 분해해요. 트로터화된 circuit을 생성한 후, 드디어
매핑 단계가 완료돼요. 이제 circuit 최적화로 넘어갈 수 있어요.
이를 위해 달성해야 할 것들이 있어요. circuit의 가상 qubit을
하드웨어의 물리적 qubit에 매핑하는 qubit 레이아웃이 필요해요. 이는 하드웨어가 특정 토폴로지를 가질 수 있어서
물리적 qubit 간의 직접적인 상호작용을 제한하기 때문이에요. 반면
quantum circuit의 구현은 보통 모든 qubit이 서로 상호작용할 수 있다고 가정해요. 그런 다음 연결되지 않은 qubit 간의
상호작용을 라우팅하기 위해 필요에 따라 swap gate를 삽입해야 해요. circuit의
gate들을 하드웨어에서 직접 실행할 수 있는 명령어 세트 아키텍처, 즉 ISA 명령어로
변환해야 해요. 그런 다음 circuit 깊이와 gate 수를 최소화하기 위해 circuit 최적화를 수행해야 해요.
이 단계는 가상 circuit에서도 수행할 수 있어요. qubit이
아직 디바이스 토폴로지에 매핑되지 않은 circuit에서요. 하지만 이 중 많은 부분이
Qiskit에서 자동으로 처리된다는 걸 기억하세요. 이번 강의의 다음 섹션에서 정확히 어떻게 되는지 볼 거예요. 최적화 단계 후에는
프리미티브를 사용해서 circuit을 실행할 준비가 된 거예요. 대부분의 시뮬레이션 실험에서는 시스템의 특정 속성이
시간에 따라 어떻게 변하는지 이해하는 데 관심이 있어요. 그래서 estimator 프리미티브를 사용할 가능성이 높은데, 이는
특정 속성에 해당하는 관측량의 기댓값을 측정할 수 있게 해줘요. 그런 다음
오류 억제 및 오류 완화 기법을 추가할 수 있는 estimator의 최적 옵션을 설정할 거예요. 마지막으로
실험을 실행해요. 마지막 단계는 모든 데이터를 후처리하는 거예요. 이를 통해 측정된 기댓값이나
sampler를 사용하는 경우 계산 기저에서의 샘플 확률 분포를 추출해요. 필요한 것이
관심 있는 관측량의 기댓값뿐이라면, estimator
프리미티브에서 원시 값과 오류 완화된 값 모두 직접 얻을 수 있어요. 그런 다음 측정된 기댓값을
양자 계산이 필요 없고 고전 컴퓨터에서 계산할 수 있는 다른 관심 있는 양의
계산에 활용할 때가 많아요.
이제 IBM이 몇 년 전에 발표한 매우 영향력 있는 논문의 실제 예시를 살펴볼 거예요. 그 논문의 제목은
"내결함성 이전 양자 컴퓨팅의 유용성에 대한 증거"예요. 이 논문은 친근하게
유틸리티 논문이라고 줄여서 부르는데, 발표 직후 양자 컴퓨팅 분야에서 매우 영향력 있는 논문이 됐어요.
논문의 전반적인 주장은 잡음 있는 양자 컴퓨터가 127개의 qubit과 2,880개의 gate를 사용해서
무차별 대입 계산 능력 밖의 정확한 결과나 기댓값을 생성했다는 거예요.
무차별 대입 계산이란 하드웨어가 실행하는 quantum circuit의 정확한 시뮬레이션이에요. 이 연구는
양자 컴퓨터를 사용해서 사전에 해답을 알 수 없는 양자 시뮬레이션을 위한
텐서 네트워크 알고리즘과 같은 다른 근사적 고전 방법들과 결과를 검증하거나 비교할 수 있다는 것을 보여줬기 때문에 중요해요.
또 꽤 멋진 점은 이제 클라우드에서 IBM 양자 시스템과 Qiskit을 사용하는
다른 사람들이 이 결과를 직접 복제하고 검증할 수 있다는 거예요.
어떻게 하는지 안내해 드릴게요. 이 예시에서는 이 문제를 양자 디바이스가 이해할 수 있는
입력으로 매핑하는 단계에 대해 좀 더 구체적으로 살펴볼 거예요. 이 경우
외부 자기장이 있는 격자 위의 자기 쌍극자 스핀 시스템의
전체 자화의 동역학을 시뮬레이션할 거예요. 이 시스템은 횡방향 자기장이 있는 이징 모델로 설명될 수 있어요.
우리는 이를 매개변수화된 quantum circuit으로 모델링하는데, 매개변수는 조절 가능한
스핀-스핀 또는 Z 상호작용 값과 자기장 X의 세기에 해당해요.
이 시리즈는 실전 양자 컴퓨팅이라는 제목이에요. 그래서 이 실험에서도
결과를 최대한 좋게 만들기 위해 구현할 절차들을 논의할 거예요. 다음으로는
실험 결과에 심각한 영향을 줄 수 있는 낮은 gate 충실도나 결어긋남 시간을 가진
불량 qubit들을 제거하는 방법을 논의할 거예요. 이런 불량 qubit들은 이전의 잘못된 보정이나
qubit과 상호작용하는 2-레벨 시스템으로 인해 발생할 수 있어요. 하드웨어 네이티브 토폴로지에서 일부 qubit을 제거하는 것은
결과적인 토폴로지로 설명되는 격자 위의 시스템을 고려하는 것에 해당해요. 또한
트로터화를 통해 시스템의 시간 진화를 구현하는 매개변수화된 quantum circuit을 만드는 것에 대해서도 논의할 거예요.
이를 위해 나중에 사용할 주요 오류 완화 기법의 핵심 부분인
얽힘 레이어를 식별하는 것이 중요해요. 이 시점에서 여러분이 아래 링크된 튜토리얼과 IBM에서
제가 곧 논의할 모든 내용을 따라할 수 있다는 걸 알려드리고 싶어요.
양자 학습 플랫폼에서요. 이 튜토리얼에서 알아두실 점은, 노트북 초반에 나중에 편하게 사용할 수 있는
헬퍼 함수 시리즈를 만들어 뒀다는 거예요. 이걸 언급하는 이유는 공식 프로세스의 일부여서가 아니라,
실제로 실험가들이 이런 종류의 실험을 운영할 때 자주 사용하는 방법이기 때문이에요.
또 문제를 어떻게 더 세분화하는지도 보여줘요.
노트북에서 정의하는 함수들은 다음과 같아요. qubit 커플링 제거,
qubit 커플링 정의, 레이어 커플링 구성, 얽힘 레이어 구성, 마지막으로 트로터화된
circuit 정의예요. 다음으로 레이어 커플링에 대해 이야기해 봐요. 레이어 커플링은 시뮬레이션 중에 qubit이
이웃 qubit들과 어떻게 상호작용하는지 정의하는 데 도움을 줘요. 우리의 양자 디바이스는 헤비 헥사고날이라고 불리는
레이아웃을 사용해요. qubit을 연결하는 특별한 패턴이에요. 이 레이아웃에서는 엣지라고 불리는 연결들을 같은 집합 내에서
두 연결이 qubit을 공유하지 않는 세 개의 분리된 집합으로 그룹화할 수 있어요.
이게 중요한 이유는 실제 양자 컴퓨터에서 같은 qubit을 포함하는 2-qubit gate를 동시에
실행할 수 없기 때문이에요. 각 qubit은 한 번에 하나의 gate에만 참여할 수 있어요.
모든 연결을 세 개의 레이어로 나눔으로써, 전체 디바이스에서 세
번의 라운드로 2-qubit gate를 적용할 수 있고, 레이어당 하나의 gate에만 qubit이 사용되도록 할 수 있어요.
이 gate들은 이징 모델의 ZZ 상호작용을 구현하며, 트로터
단계라고 불리는 시뮬레이션의 각 단계에서 반복돼요. 트월링은 디바이스의 노이즈를 수정해서 단순한 노이즈 모델조차도
정확할 가능성을 높여요. 또한 노이즈 모델을 정확하게 학습하고 얻은
정보와 오류 완화 기법을 사용하는 것도 가능하게 해줘요.
다음으로, 실험에 사용할 수 있는 물리적 qubit 목록에서 불량 qubit을 제거해야 해요.
앞서 말씀드린 것처럼, qubit은 다양한 이유로 불량이 될 수 있어요. 때로는 단순히 잘못된
보정으로 인한 것이라서 다시 보정하면 해결되는 단순한 실수예요.
때로는 좀 더 복잡해서 TLS라고 부르는 것과 관련이 있는데, 이는 2-레벨 계면
결함으로 qubit 매개변수 변동과 이완을 일으켜요.
이는 전체 시스템을 약간 가열했다가 다시 냉각하면 해결되는데, 시간이 좀 걸리고 클라우드에서는
할 수가 없어요. 그래서 지금은 그냥 사용할 물리적 qubit 목록에서 제외하는 게 가장
쉬운 방법이에요. IBM 양자 플랫폼에서 어떤 qubit이 예상대로 작동하지 않는지 쉽게 파악할 수 있어요.
플랫폼에서 qubit 특성을 플롯하거나 CSV로 다운로드할 수 있어요. 그런 다음 제외하고 싶은 모든
qubit 목록을 만들고 디바이스의 전체 물리적 qubit 목록에서 간단히 제거하면 돼요.
좋아요. 이제 트로터화된 circuit을 생성하는 매핑 단계를 계속해 봐요. 앞서 보여드린 것처럼
트로터화는 시간 진화를 일련의 단계로 이산화하는데, 단계 수를 결정해야 해요.
여기서는 여섯 단계를 선택할 거예요. 하지만 일반적인 전략은 트로터 오류라고 불리는 것의 균형을 맞추는 건데,
이는 결어긋남에서 발생하는 오류와의 알고리즘 근사 오류예요. 트로터 단계가 많을수록 근사
오류는 줄어들지만 더 많은 결어긋남 노이즈를 경험하는 더 깊은 quantum circuit이 필요해요. circuit을
theta 매개변수, 즉 외부 자기장의 세기, 레이어 커플링, 그리고
단계 수와 qubit 수, 물론 디바이스 backend를 기준으로 정의할 거예요.
외부 자기장의 세기에 따른 시스템 자화의 의존성 때문에, 다양한 자기장 세기 값에서
시뮬레이션을 실행하는 게 흥미로운데, 이는 circuit에서의 RX 회전의
다양한 각도로 변환돼요. circuit을 생성했으니 이제 최적화로 넘어갈게요.
여기서 첫 번째 단계는 pass manager를 정의하는 거예요. Qiskit SDK의 맥락에서 transpilation은
입력 circuit을 양자 디바이스에서 실행하기에 적합한 형태로 변환하는 과정이에요.
Transpilation은 일반적으로 transpiler 패스라고 불리는 일련의 단계로 이루어져요. pass manager는
transpiler 패스 목록을 저장하고 circuit에서 실행할 수 있는 객체예요. transpiler 패스 목록으로
pass manager 객체를 초기화해서 pass manager를 만들 수 있어요. 결국 pass manager는
ISA circuit을 만드는데, 이는 backend의 instruction set architecture 형태로 작성된 circuit으로,
backend에 네이티브한 circuit과 gate를 설명하지만 circuit을 실행하는 데 필요한 타이밍 정보는 없어요.
이제 Qiskit 패턴의 3단계인 circuit 실행 준비가 됐어요. 앞서 말씀드린 것처럼 시스템의
전체 자화를 측정하고 싶기 때문에 이 실험에서는 estimator를 프리미티브로 사용할 거예요.
관측량의 기댓값을 추정하는 게 estimator가 설계된 목적이기 때문이에요.
이 단계에서 오류 완화 옵션을 지정하는 것도 중요해요. 최상의 결과를 얻기 위해 제로 노이즈 외삽을 사용할 거예요. 특히 튜토리얼에서는
외삽 모델을 평가할 두 개 이상의 노이즈 인자 값을 지정하고
확률적 오류 증폭을 증폭 옵션으로 지정하는 것을 볼 수 있어요.
확률적 오류 증폭, 즉 PA는
다른 옵션들보다 훨씬 더 잘 확장되기 때문에 여기서 선택한 오류 완화 기법이었어요.
100개 이상의 qubit 수준에서 작업할 때 중요한 점이에요.
마지막으로 실험을 실행하면 완료하는 데 시간이 걸리는데, 지금은 튜토리얼에서 큐에 등록되고 저장된
데이터를 참조할게요. 메타데이터를 검토하면서 레이어드 gate와 원시 데이터에서 많은 오류를 제거하는 데 사용할
완화된 레이어에 특히 주목할 거예요. 최종 결과를 플롯할 준비가 거의 됐는데, 그 전에
제로 노이즈 외삽이 정확히 무엇을 의미하는지에 대해 잠깐 이야기해 봐요.
이전 에피소드에서 간략히 다뤘는데, 복습하자면 제로 노이즈 외삽, 즉 ZNE는
circuit 실행 중 알 수 없는 노이즈의 영향을 제거하는 오류 완화 기법으로, 노이즈를
알려진 방식으로 조정할 수 있어요. 기댓값이 여기에 표시된 알려진 함수에 의해 노이즈와 함께 스케일된다고 가정해요.
람다 매개변수는 노이즈 세기를 지정하고 증폭할 수 있어요. ZNE는 다음 단계로 구현할 수 있어요.
먼저 여러 노이즈 인자에 대해 circuit 노이즈를 증폭해요. 람다 1, 람다 2,
람다 3 등등이에요. 노이즈가 증폭된 모든 circuit을 실행해서
람다 1의 기댓값 a, 람다 2의 기댓값 a 등을 측정해요. 그런 다음 제로 노이즈
한계인 기댓값 a(0)으로 외삽해요.
ZNE를 성공적으로 구현하는 데 있어 주요 과제는 기댓값에서의 노이즈에 대한 정확한 모델을 갖추고
노이즈를 알려진 방식으로 증폭하는 거예요.
ZNE에서 오류 증폭을 구현하는 세 가지 일반적인 방법이 있어요. 보정을 통한 펄스 지속 시간 스케일 조정,
항등 사이클에서 gate 반복, 그리고 파울리 채널 샘플링을 통한 노이즈 추가예요.
후자를 PA라고 부르는데, 확률적 오류 증폭이 여기서 최선의 선택이에요. 펄스 스트레칭은 계산 비용이 매우
크거든요. Gate 폴딩은 노이즈 바이어스 보존에 대한 이론적 보장이 없어요. 하지만 PA는
네이티브 노이즈 인자로 실행할 수 있는 모든 circuit에 적용할 수 있지만 노이즈 모델 학습이 필요해요. PA는
확률적 오류 소거와 동일한 레이어 기반 노이즈 모델을 가정해요.
하지만 circuit 노이즈에 따라 지수적으로 증가하는 샘플링 오버헤드를 피할 수 있어요. 노이즈 모델을 학습하려면
먼저 circuit에서 2-qubit 연산의 고유한 레이어를 파악해야 해요.
각 레이어에 대해 노이즈가 감쇠 노이즈 모델로 잘 설명되도록 2-qubit gate를 파울리 트월해요.
다양한 깊이에서 레이어의 항등 쌍을 반복하고, 마지막으로 각 노이즈 채널에 대한 충실도 또는 오류를 피팅해요.
물론 이 방법을 어느 정도 이해하는 것을 권장하지만, Qiskit에서 직접 하는 것은
튜토리얼에서 보여주는 것처럼 훨씬 더 간단해요. 자, 이제 드디어 플롯된 데이터를 살펴봐요. 점선으로 된
회색 선은 근사 오류가 낮은 임계값으로 수렴하는 근사적 고전 방법으로 얻은 정확한 결과를 보여줘요.
보시다시피, 처음에 선택한 다양한 노이즈 인자에 대한 원시 데이터는 이 점선에서 꽤 멀리 떨어져 있어요.
파란 실선은 ZNE 처리를 반영한 데이터를 보여줘요.
정확한 결과에 훨씬 더 가깝다는 걸 바로 알 수 있어요.
요약하자면, 노이즈가 있는 값은 정확한 값에서 크게 벗어나요.
완화된 값은 정확한 값에 가까워서 PA 기반 완화 기법의 유용성을 보여줘요.
이것으로 이번 에피소드가 마무리돼요. 배운 내용을 간략히 요약하자면, 양자 시뮬레이션은
단기에서 중기적으로 가장 유망한 응용 분야 중 하나예요.
의약품부터 고에너지 물리학,
재료 과학 등 다양한 분야에 응용될 수 있어요. 2023년 IBM이 발표한 유틸리티 논문은
과학적 발견을 위해 양자 컴퓨터를 사용하는 방향을 제시했어요. 그리고 우리는 그
논문과 함께 제공되는 관련 튜토리얼을 심층적으로 살펴봤어요. 처음부터 끝까지 시뮬레이션 문제를 풀어나가는 단계들은
특히 익숙해지면 비교적 간단해요. 앞으로 여러분이
이 영상과 튜토리얼을 더 많은 시뮬레이션 문제를 위한 가이드로 활용할 수 있기를 바라요.
시청해 주셔서 감사해요. Quantum Computing in Practice에서 다음에 만나요.